in this lesson we're going to learn to
sketch the molecular orbitals for pi
systems this is important because
there's some reactions in organic
chemistry that don't really have a clear
electrophile and nucleophile but they
proceed anyway let's look at the
diels-alder reaction in this reaction a
butadiene will react with an alkene to
produce a cyclohexene when heated up now
this is a bit of a tough reaction here
this doesn't proceed very readily
ethylene is a gas we need to do this in
a sealed tube we need to heat it to
about 200 degrees it's actually better
if these compounds are substituted and
when this butadiene has electron
donating groups on it and this alkene
has electron withdrawing groups on it
the reaction proceeds more readily the
details of that are best left for
another lesson but what I want to show
you is how we can push arrows for this
transformation now you should notice we
don't have a clear electrophile in
nucleophile we're looking at some fairly
nonpolar molecules but we get these new
bonds to form and so we can show our
conventional arrow pushing remember
that's just a tool to keep track of
where the electrons form the bonds and
so we could show the alkene forming a
new bond here these electrons are going
to shift over to make our double bond
and finally these electrons will
complete this circular flow of electrons
to form the new bond here now imagine we
want to react two molecules of an alkene
in a similar fashion this reaction is
called a 2+2 cycloaddition and now if we
imagine two molecules of ethylene
reacting in a similar fashion we might
imagine we can do arrow pushing like
this to form a cyclo butane and for
consistency let's imagine we're heating
up this reaction mixture as we did over
here now heating up a reaction can be
called thermal conditions and though
will find that the diels-alder can
proceed under thermal conditions this
2+2 cycloaddition will not proceed so
even though we could draw arrows here
this
reaction doesn't proceed and to
understand why we need to look at the
molecular orbitals so let's learn how to
sketch them we'll begin by looking at
the molecular orbitals for ethylene
we'll draw an energy diagram now notice
this reaction is a rearrangement of
double bonds so for this example we
really need to look at the P orbitals to
sketch out this PI system we'll begin by
drawing two P orbitals side by side to
represent the orbitals on these carbon
atoms now you might remember that we
usually represent a p orbital as being
shaded on one side and unshaded on the
other side let's show that for our
orbital over here on the left
now this p orbital itself contains a
node right in the center this is where
the wave function changes sign and
there's actually no probability of
finding an electron right here now to
form our first molecular orbital this is
going to combine with another p orbital
and in this lower energy molecular
orbital that we're about to sketch the
shaded sides are going to line up and
the unshaded sides will line up like
this when the shaded and unshaded sides
line up like this we say that these
orbitals are in phase so we're showing
these as two separate P orbitals because
it's easy to sketch it that way in
reality these orbitals combine and give
us a molecular orbital that looks more
like this now for each atom in our PI
system we're going to have a separate
molecular orbital let's again draw two P
orbitals side-by-side now instead of
combining in phase as we've shown here
these orbitals will combine in a fashion
that is out of phase so here I'm going
to shade the top of this orbital and the
bottom of this orbital this creates a
higher energy orbital with a node right
in the center so there is no probability
of finding an electron in this region
and the actual molecular orbital looks
something like this
now we need to populate the MOS with the
electrons from the PI's
system of ethylene and I'll draw some
little lines to show where we can put
our electrons potentially now we can
have a maximum of two electrons in each
of these molecular orbitals and we start
by populating the lower energy molecular
orbital so for our two electrons we only
need to put them in the lower energy M
oh that was all in phase this orbital
containing the electrons is called a
bonding molecular orbital and this
orbital up here with how electrons in it
is called an antibonding molecular
orbital there's some other language that
we use to describe these molecular
orbitals and so the one with the
electrons is going to be the highest
orbital containing electrons so we call
this the highest occupied molecular
orbital abbreviated homo then our lowest
energy molecular orbital without
electrons is called the LUMO so this is
the lowest unoccupied molecular orbital
here now let's look at the allyl cation
and anion to see how the homo and LUMO
may change the allyl cation is a 3
carbon system containing an alkene and a
carbo cation we can draw resonance for
this cation pushing these electrons over
here which results in a resonance form
that looks like this so this is a 3
electron system the double bond has two
P orbitals and then we have an empty p
orbital for this carbo cation the allyl
anion looks like this we have our PI
system and conjugation with this anion
we can push two arrows to show our
resonance form which can be depicted
like this let's draw our energy diagram
and sketch out our molecular orbitals we
now have three carbon atoms in our PI
system so we're going to expect three
molecular orbitals I'll draw a p orbital
on each of these carbon atoms
notice that I've drawn the p orbital on
the middle carbon atom a bit larger than
the ones on the end
this is actually how it exists it's a
consequence of the mathematics that
describes the wave function it's a
little beyond our scope today but I did
want to try to depict it accurately but
now what we need to do is put all of
these orbitals in phase as we did for
ethylene here so it doesn't matter if I
shade the top or the bottom but each of
these orbitals has to combine in phase
okay let's draw our second molecular
orbital now again because of the
mathematics that describe the wave
functions we want to draw this orbital
as symmetrically as possible and we're
going to have one node representing
where the wave function changes phase
because we need to do this with as much
symmetry as possible the node is going
to go straight through our central
carbon atom so we don't even draw an
orbital on this carbon atom there's no
probability of finding the electron
there and then we shade our molecular
orbitals out of phase because they need
to switch sign where the node is as they
did here
so in our lowest energy molecular
orbital we had zero nodes here we had
one and guess what in this one we're
going to have two nodes to separate them
with as much symmetry as possible but go
right about here and here so we can see
that they're not really transecting any
of the carbon atoms like we have in this
molecular orbital so we'll draw a p
orbital on each of our atoms our nodes
will be here and here so I'll shade the
top lobe here in order to show the node
I'll shade the bottom lobe here and then
again we shade the top lobe here now we
want to populate these orbitals with the
electrons that we have in our PI system
we'll have to do this separately for the
cation and the anion so for our cation
in this PI system we only have two
electrons we have the carbo cation which
is an empty p orbital we'll put these
two electrons in our lowest energy mo
now for the allyl anion this is a
different store
we have two four electrons that we need
to place into these orbitals populate
them two at a time beginning with the
orbital of lowest energy here's our
first pair and our second pair so for
the ll cation this is our homo and this
is our LUMO whereas for the allyl anion
this is our homo and this is our LUMO
so let's come back to talking about
reactions for a second the reason that
reactions can occur is because a highest
occupied molecular orbital interacts
with a lowest unoccupied molecular
orbital something with electrons can
interact with a molecular orbital that
doesn't contain electrons and this is
how all bonding happens even if we
represent it as an arrow coming from a
nucleophile and attacking an
electrophile so to contrast the a low
cation and anion homos in the cation we
have everything in phase so the phasing
on these terminal carbons is unshaded
unshaded
but for the homo of the allyl anion we
have a different pattern okay let's look
at one more set of molecular orbitals
for butadiene now and then let's see if
we can't make sense of this reactivity
pattern will again set up our energy
diagram we now have 1 2 3 4 carbon atoms
in our PI system we'll set that up
looking like this similar to the way
we've drawn butadiene up here draw in
our P orbitals and our lowest energy
molecular orbital is going to have 0
nodes so we will shade this all in phase
our next molecular orbital is going to
have one node because of the mathematics
underlying these wave functions we want
the node to be in a position that gives
the most symmetry so a single node will
go in between these two central carbon
atoms remember this is where the wave
function changes sign so we'll shade the
left-hand side in phase switch the sign
here at the node and
shade these two in phase so for this MEC
molecular orbital we're going to need to
have two nodes to place them as
symmetrically as possible maybe one will
be right here and one about here at any
rate there between the carbon atoms not
transecting them as we have with our al
L cation and anion and now we can add
our phasing the highest energy molecular
orbital will have three nodes in between
each of the carbon atoms and it looks
like this let's add our electrons so we
have two four electrons in our PI system
and so these two orbitals will be
populated so this molecular orbital is
our homo and this one our LUMO now
remember I said that we need a homo LUMO
interaction for the diels-alder reaction
or any reaction really to precede this
homo here for butadiene is higher in
energy than the homo for ethylene and
it's actually closer to the energy of
the LUMO now the lower this energy gap
makes the reaction easier so we'll just
say that for now without going into a
whole ton of detail here but this
consideration makes butadiene react with
its home oh with the ethylene LUMO so
let's sketch out what that interaction
looks like so we'll draw in our homo for
butadiene and our LUMO for ethylene and
what we'll notice is these orbitals line
up really well the shaded sides can line
up over here and then the unshaded sides
can line up over here so as these two
molecules approach each other
we get favorable in phase orbital
interactions that allows this reaction
to proceed now let's take a quick peek
at our 2+2 cycloaddition for this to
proceed we'd need the homo of ethylene
to interact with a LUMO of ethylene like
we did for the diels-alder let's just
draw our homo on top and our LUMO below
notice on this side of our system the
orbital overlap is good however this
side of the molecular orbital is out
of Fay's we can't have an interaction
over here because the orbitals don't
line up
and so this 2+2 cycloaddition does not
proceed under thermal conditions however
we can get this reaction to go by using
photochemical conditions photochemical
conditions excite electrons to a the
next orbital and this will create a new
homo this is actually a reaction that
can cause skin cancer when the Sun hits
your skin it can cause these 2 plus 2
cyclo additions to form these thymine
dimers so this does happen but cannot
happen under thermal conditions well I
hope you learned something from this
lesson I hope this helped you to sketch
molecular orbitals and I hope you join
me again to learn some more chemistry in
the future please subscribe and click
that notification bell and I'll see you
soon